happy thursday everyone so it's
beginning to look a lot like christmas
we're getting signs of snow that for
once isn't under cat's nose
but nothing says the holiday spirit like
boarded up storefronts and high-end
shopping districts
sorry rich bay area liberals your
stocking is going to be emptier than joy
reid's head
thanks to the rise in smash and grabs
places like union square and san fran
are boarding up more businesses than
minneapolis did while waiting for the
chovin verdict deck the halls has been
replaced with deck the security guard
who needs mistletoe when you can kiss
your ass goodbye
whether it's brutal home invasions or
grizzly street attacks santa's naughty
list is growing faster than alec
baldwin's legal bills
police officers have been shot and
killed this year at all-time highs 314
officers were shot so far a 43 percent
increase since 2018. ambush attacks are
up 126 since 2020 and in almost every
major city murder rates are the highest
in 30 years merry christmas
crime's up cause crime pays and the only
people getting punished are people who
don't break the law even the kids are
catching on
hi mr bitterman it's me charlie mom says
santa sent me some amazon packages but i
think they got stolen
well they definitely did get stolen and
i know that because i stole them well
you're going to be on the naughty list
but you know whose list i'm not going to
be on the district attorneys because
like me they don't give a sh you'll get
calling your stocky mr bitterman
oh not valuable coal do you want to
throw in some natural gas too so i can
heat my apartment you know every minute
i spent talking to you i'm wasting money
can't you get me something for christmas
charlie i'm going to give you the
greatest gift of all a lesson
my hat
my tree
say hi to your mom for me
[Laughter]
now i'm always skeptical of someone who
explains a big problem by saying just
connect the dots especially if that
someone is a shirtless kill mead and
he's handing me a magic marker
but usually what follows that is an
insane conspiracy theory involving
extraterrestrials satanic rituals and
lizard people which sounds like one of
bill hammer's hot tub parties
but whenever i hear of another terrible
crime i keep asking why and how it's the
same thing er doctors ask me after
looking at an x-ray of my colon
but this time connecting the dots is
super easy because the left has given us
more dots than a braille edition of moby
dick
first chicago so far it's had the most
homicides since 1994 more than a
thousand during kim fox's first three
years as the county's top prosecutor her
office dropped all charges against 30
percent of felony defendants a massive
increase over her predecessor and
despite having video evidence and
witnesses to crimes connected to death
she declines charging anyone of course
she also fell for jesse smallett who's
on trial for a hoax that was as
believable as a tom cruise marriage
she treated smilet like he was the
second coming of mlk even as this story
fell apart like a bridge designed by a
woman's studies major
thank you
but
a sexist would say but she got millions
millions from george soros two million
to be exact
and that's a dot
now you know that the wakisha waukesha
madman had been released on a small bale
despite having a history that would make
ivan the terrible blush the least they
could do was take away his car keys
which is good advice for violent
criminals or joe biden
john chisholm the d.a who set him free
had pledged to work with the san
francisco d.a jason bouden san francisco
have you seen that hell hole since
boudin's been in office
now the san francisco treat means
stepping on a used syringe while a [ __ ]
defecates on your shoes
and yeah boudin was put in office using
soros foundation money another dot
in philly homicides have more than
doubled since larry krasner was elected
d.a in 2017. the city of brotherly love
is now the city of duck and run which is
what happens when a d.a would rather
release criminals than prosecute them
and the criminals who get second chances
they get arrested again sometimes for
murder krasner received 1.7 million in
backing from soros
anybody else connecting the
blood-splattered dots
then there's la's george gascon another
far-left reformer bankrolled by soros's
millions he's now like boudin facing a
recall after replacing the rule of law
with weak sentencing for violent thugs
gascon redefined victimhood so victims
aren't just those targeted by criminals
but the criminals themselves so wherever
crimes exploding you find these dots
progressive soros-backed prosecutors
like maroon 5's latest tour
wherever they go people suffer
it's like the radical left is running a
medical experiment and we're the lab
rats and if there's collateral damage
well the overarching mission justifies
it they've said so it's like making an
omelet if you want to make res
remake society you're gonna have to
crack a few skulls
and like scientists who conduct medical
experiments they're well protected but
the rats aren't so you see the pattern
eliminate bail requirements stop
prosecuting crimes and use the pandemic
to release even more violent thugs
because god forbid a rapist has to
suffer mild flu symptoms at rikers
all of these dots end up creating a line
pointing you to widespread brutality
against minorities the elderly and now
even the rich but you can't blame soros
alone it's not like he created these
people he may not be a dot but he sure
knows how to connect him but it's like
blaming the jets owner for the team's
horrible record the last 10 years he
didn't create these bad players he just
pays them he's writing checks for their
mayhem just like the one jesse smilet
wrote to his fake assailants except here
and now the damage they do is real
[Applause]
tonight's guess
he needs a constitutional amendment to
bear those arms retired u.s marine corps
bomb technician and fox contributor
johnny joey jones
[Music]
he's got the name of a male stripper and
the hair of a lego figure radio and
podcast host [ __ ] sexton
he can't walk around with a coffee cup
without someone throwing change into it
the loftus party.com founder michael
loved us
she's like tinsel
thin glittery and ends up on the floor
under your christmas tree fox news
contributor captain
all right i'm gonna go to you first buck
buck buck buck i'm going coming to you
for answers yes sir because i don't know
what you can do about these da's and i'm
thinking like
why why was it that you could not
mention george soros without being
connected to like tin foil like why was
that the case well in this case it's
because he really was the guy writing
the check yes so so because he was
really behind all the stuff we're
talking about with the progressive
prosecutor project which goes back
really to 2016. that was when a lot of
this money started getting going and i
think it was part of the hashtag
resistance right you've got the trump
administration you need to have
bureaucrats and in this case people that
are elected to offices that nobody
really pays attention to when you look
at d.a races it doesn't take a lot of
money to sway one where you're putting a
million dollars behind somebody they're
basically going to win and you get the
most progressive far left people why
does this change the numbers are crazy
right now right a thousand shootings in
portland who thinks of portland as a
place a thousand this year alone 500
murders in philadelphia if that was new
york city it would be back to 1992
levels where we had about 2200 murders
in new york so i think people realize it
turns out when you put loons who are
like let's let all the criminals out of
prison or not punish people harshly who
are criminals bad things happen in
cities and it's not even just the big
ones lansing wichita you go to mid-sized
cities all across america they have
progressive prosecutors too by the way
places like milwaukee progressive
prosecutors
yep and it's spreading everywhere uh
loftus r.i.p
to the bomb you murdered for that jacket
[Laughter]
you know what he died smiling knowing
that the jacket would be famous well you
know he thought well at least the jacket
will be on the show
not me
so i guess that's progress you know
this is a very depressing topic to me
because this is these are all
unavoidable problems created by people
who believe crime is not an issue and
they and they're willing to let people
suffer yeah it's really like james bond
super villain level stuff yeah yeah like
george soros i'll get this d.a elected
and then the criminals will run for it's
like i can remember people trying to
tell me about soros like 10 years ago
but it was like talking about voldemort
in harry potter right they never like to
use this guy george soros and now he's
like on the front page of the new york
post they're like hey pure evil george
soros yeah so there's at least that
going on but i mean i i used to make fun
of it too it's because i don't like the
the the single variable kind of thinking
where it's like oh it's bill gates is
trying to poison you no you're crazy
like there's a lot of gates and george
sorority
it's two variables it's bill gates and
soros
and fouchy but no but there's a lot
there's a lot of variables dealing with
crime no cash bail prosecutors not
prosecuting accusations of racism if you
defend the police the demoralization of
the police joey so what do you what do
you what do you see what is your wisdom
well first of all as the guy with the
removable parts i love the lego haircut
that was really good i like and it's
like and i love it i grew up playing
with legos and if you ever want to hang
out man let me know comes right off
reminisce on that yeah
you can take your his legs and your hair
and god knows my jacket and your jacket
everything is awesome and you know i
love the monologue it's like all the
christmas cheer we're going to line the
stage with poinsettias and talk about
crime that's just where we are well do
you have any suggestions
yes okay what are they here's the
problem
no i have no suggestions i'm sorry
here's a problem with what we're dealing
with today with where crime is though
the more you have to lose the more the
rules apply to you
so it's not so much that i'm bothered
that other people are getting away with
things it's the fact that i know i could
not
like like for example who are they going
to pull over and write a speed and
ticket too the dude that looks like he
would probably pay it because that's
mutually beneficial for them right
that's a fair point it's like you know
i'm just gonna this guy looks like he's
he's you know looks like he'll pay a
ticket i'm just gonna pull him over if
we're going five ten or 35 miles over
the speed limit like i would do i get
pulled over a lot but i don't get a lot
of tickets thankfully um and so what
really bothers me about is is we have a
system now that not only
omits people from having to pay
consequences but it rewards them right
it rewards people for not having
anything to lose when you get pulled
over a ticket do you go just excuse me
officer let me take off one of my legs
did you kind of hand it to him can you
hold this for me no well you know you're
supposed to put your hands out the
window so i'll just throw the hands and
the legs out the window
looks like i'm directing traffic
only joey can make those jokes normally
what i say is i hope he's not joking you
should do that
normally what i say is did you not see
the purple heart sticker
like what are we doing here
i got to get one of those
um
i think it's good there's i hate to say
that there's some optimism in the future
but you're seeing that these crimes now
are no longer in the bronx or the south
side of chicago or on a train in philly
we're seeing horrible stuff happening
happening in beverly hills and that
makes you it's optimistic
i mean maybe liberals rich liberals in
california might go okay it's time to
really get rid of these da's so i mean
it's a sad it's sad that it has to come
to this obviously i don't want anybody
killed unless you know it's him yeah but
i don't yeah i guess
that was so in your face
i guess i just i think that it's they're
still too afraid of the canceling that
would probably actually occur like
that's not an unfounded fear right in
some of the circles that they run in but
at this point i just feel stupid
because i'm still buying things
yes like i'm still buying things exactly
with money right but i go to work to
earn i know i'm an idiot sucker
and they they probably have nicer things
than i do oh well that's that's they're
robbing they're that's a low ball
getting together with their friends i do
i dress like trash i have trash stuff
yeah and i throw they're just why don't
why am i i've got friends yes why don't
we go rob some places it is true but i
do i do feel like we're the
you we're all suckers for what are we
doing going to work
i was the victim of a crime a few blocks
from here just last week someone stole
my electric scooter from right outside
of where i was having and he's probably
having a great day on your electric
scooter yeah he went like five miles an
hour as part of the escape but you know
broke the lock thing i had and just took
off with my scooter i didn't see him and
then the hotel that had footage was like
only with a subpoena i was like it's the
street you're not gonna show me
that's probably better i'd like to
publicly apologize
all right it was a great scooter though
you don't want me riding a scooter yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's got it's got flames
on the side
no shagging wagon
that's an old school route that's a
13-year callback